lessons from up north that's the focus
of tonight's angle
all right just when you think that cnn
can't sink lower they surprise you
they are so lazy so unimaginative and so
bereft of fresh thinking
that now they just cut and paste their
scripts about january 6th
and apply them to any protest or rally
against left-wing government overreach
now case in point is their coverage of
canada's expanding freedom convoy
now note the reporter's exasperated tone
and pained expressions
state of emergency in place in ottawa
where the police chief says covet
protests are a quote nationwide
insurrection driven by madness just
think of the language i know it sounds
familiar to you right a threat to
democracy an insurrection sedition
things have quieted it down a bit but
that does not take away from the basic
truck in right the sit-in sitting
senators sitting at least one sitting
governor are supporting these people
from the united states the police chief
has a message for them don't the you are
supporting unlawful behavior
well that's the same way basically they
covered the blm protests right
this is atlanta a bit of the the outrage
expressed across the country
this is right outside of cnn world
headquarters they broke the the glass
that was right in front it's not the
main interest of the cnn
they didn't break the main entrance just
some of the glass it's like they're
building in atlanta now you get the
point
the regime media knows exactly what's
happening in canada and it scares the
heck out of them now it's not because
they think the truckers or the truckers
supporters are terrorists they know
they're not
but they're scared because if usually
mild-mannered canadians have figured
things out that most of what their
governments did to fight covid was
insanely destructive
then how can liberals here possibly
think for one second that they're going
to keep this coveted theater going on in
the united states for much longer
so back to cnn rather than seriously
reporting on these unprecedented
grassroots protests
the cnn and the backbenchers denigrate
or dismiss them
i'm telling you tonight this is a huge
mistake
people and viewers follow strength and
courage
not small men like jeff zucker or the
dewey face justin trudeau
who as far as we can tell still hiding
in an undisclosed location tonight
for two weeks now canada has seen what
happens to to a supposedly free people
when they're pushed to the brink
out of touch provincial governments
drunk on their own power
thought that they could keep canadians
subdued with these coveted rules forever
but they were wrong
the situation in canada is a preview of
what would have happened here if we
didn't have a strong populist movement
that listens to america's working-class
voters
in canada workers have a lot less hope
than we have here so they're turning to
more radical actions
for years canada's mainline leaders like
our establishment here frankly did
everything they could to help china at
the expense of their own people
then came woke ideology and
condemnations of canadian history and
patriotism
unlike here where populists in the gop
were able to take over their party and
offer an alternative governing approach
the canadian conservative party was led
by a limp-wristed moderate who tried to
pull his party to the left it's crazy
but let's review what happened in canada
just over the past few years
in june of 2020 blm radicals took over
parliament hill in ottawa
naturally pretty boy trudeau was there
to take a knee
then in montreal in august of 2020
leftists tore down and decapitated a
statue of canada's first prime minister
in july 2021 the liberal mob cheered as
they tore down statues of queen victoria
and queen elizabeth ii
so what is this all taught average
canadians
that their government is more concerned
about heaping more and more restrictions
and rules on the working class and
sucking up to the workstars than
standing up to the radical left
and by hammering working-class canadians
while enabling and praising the leftists
those in charge were inviting a blow up
and boy have they gotten one
at least the conservative party at this
point in canada is looking for new
leadership though the canadian liberal
party is stuck with its positively
boosted
cutie pie who doesn't like other boys
playing in his sandbox
vaccinations
have also chosen to not go anywhere near
protests that have expressed hateful
rhetoric the
small fringe
minority of people who are on their way
to ottawa or who are
holding unacceptable
view do not represent
the views of canadians
a small group of people doesn't he look
like he's looking for like a pilates
class anyone have a good
home teacher can come
but it looks like justin's strategy
really did
fail didn't calm things down at all
look at the crowds
now i see these protests happening every
other week for almost 18 months across
europe
in france in italy and elsewhere people
are out there demanding their basic
freedoms
and when i see it
i have to say
thank god for our red state governors
they started our own freedom convoys
back in may of 2020 by pushing to open
their states or never closing them in
the first place
now it never made sense that kids in
florida had normal school experience for
almost the entire pandemic while new
yorker kids were masked and separated
from each other
and i also think thank god we have a
republican party that has almost
entirely
rejected its old guard
we're not the party of liz cheney and
mitt romney who wouldn't know how to
fight for the average blue-collar worker
in america if their lives depended on it
conservatives in canada did everything
that romney and cheyney wanted they had
a moderate leader named aaron o'toole
who ran on a progressive platform in
2021 as the washington post noted he ran
as an explicit centrist a man at payne's
to emphasize how he revised conservative
party pro-lgbt pro-choice pro-carbon tax
pro-immigrant spend happy against budget
cuts and so on
he was not your dad's conservative party
well it failed spectacularly as a result
the liberals were still able to cling to
power in the 2021 election there
so many working-class canadians saw how
this all worked out and they essentially
for at least now they gave up on a
political solution
and now canada's problems are bigger
than ever
but here thankfully things are different
and tens of millions of us see real
reason for hope
it's a fact that the movement trump
began has already taken power in many
states school boards
man they're looking over their shoulders
now aren't they
people are demanding more law
enforcement given the crime rates and
hispanics
are moving to the gop in record numbers
we have an incredible new hispanic voice
later on in the show you got to stick
around for that
and even some blue states are starting
to drop their mandates
so will we need our own trucker rally to
end all of this insanity once and for
all
i thought not
until biden spoke through sake today
back on the mass mandate question in new
jersey in other states the cdc is still
recommending universal masking in
schools that's correct and that still
remains our recommendation
just think
honking really loud honking may keep joe
from his usual 12 hours of sleep a night
and that's the angle